we're looking at vaccines in a special
issue of science because there's been a
loud if small minority of vaccine
resistors who've been getting a lot of
play lately and we feel it's really
important to look at the facts and the
evidence around vaccines and the
tremendous public health benefit they've
delivered to us throughout the 20th
century and that they continue to do I
Meredith Wadman I'm a reporter with
science magazine we are the common
misconceptions around vaccines with
hesitant parents if this notion that
vaccines given an infancy can overwhelm
the baby's immune system or the
toddler's immune system even if you gave
a one-year-old 11 vaccines in one city
that stimulus to that child's immune
system would so-called use up only 0.1
percent of the immune system at that
point in time so we are tremendously
evolved to fight Lauren invaders and and
the number of vaccines is just not
consequential in terms of where our
immune systems abilities are when you
look at the measles line what you see
there are literally millions of cases in
the middle of the twentieth century
going down to thousands after the
introduction of the measles vaccine in
1963 measles was no joke it was no fun
for an ordinary kid to have it but for
certain children needles could kill you
you look now into the late decades of
the 20th century and measles with more
or less going away there's a bump in
ninety one or two when there's an
outbreak but then you get in nineteen
ninety eight this since proven
fraudulent paper in The Lancet from
Andrew Wakefield suggesting that there's
a link that MMR the measles mumps and
rubella vaccine might cause autism but
that had a really serious impact on
vaccination uptake for an
number of years vaccine Court is a court
in Washington DC where a petitioner
someone who believes they have been
injured by a vaccine can bring a
petition and seek redress in terms of
financial compensation for that injury
they look at the evidence and they
decide what a bonafide a vaccine
injuries by far the most common injury
where a needle is mistakenly inserted
into the shoulder joint rather than the
upper arm and causes a really painful
and long-lasting inflammation the number
of claims of shoulder injuries is
growing I believe for a couple reasons
in 2005 the government added to the list
of vaccines against which one can bring
a claim at the vaccine court the
influenza vaccine and it so happened
that at that time the CDC also expanded
the recommendation for who should be
receiving that vaccine so as a result in
the last decade you've had more than a
billion with a B doses of this vaccine
shipped more vaccines more potential for
injury however I think one interesting
and salient point is that the court has
never found that a vaccine caused a
child to develop autism there was a big
group claim of more than five thousand
families involved in this in the first
decade of this century and the court
just said there's no there there you
could come away with a very skewed
perception that vaccines are incredibly
risky in fact it's the other way around
if you are infected with tetanus in this
country the mortality for any given
individual is at a risk of actually
thirteen point two percent for any given
person who contacts
the risk of getting a really severe
allergic reaction that can kill you
is somewhere between one to six and
every million doses of tetanus vaccine
administered the risk reward calculus is
pretty obvious I think you too far
better to get your tetanus vaccine
[Music]